Here were the three answers. Great work if you got at least two of these
correct. let's see how we can simplify each one. The quickest way to simplify
the square root of 80, is to rewrite 80 as 16 times 5. We take the square root
of 16, which is 4, and then we leave the 5 inside of the radical, since we
can't simplify it. It's not a perfect square. You might of thought to do this
as well. You might of said 80 equals 8 times 10, and then you might of split 8
into 4 times 2 and 10 into 2 times 5. We know 2 times 2 equals 4 so we really
have a group of two 4s. Because we have two 4s, and our index is a 2 since
we're taking a square root. We can pull one 4 out in front of the radical. So
we have 4 times the square root of 5. For 120, we split this number up into 12
times 10, and then 3 times 4 times 2 times 5. The only perfect square factor in
this radical is the 4. So we take the square root of 4, which gives us 2. The
other factors are not perfect squares. So they need to stay within the radical.
So we have 3 times 2 which is 6. Times five which equals 30. For this last week
and split of 180 into 10 times 18. We split up the 10 into 5 times 2 and the 18
into 2 times 9. Notice that we have a perfect square of 9 here, also we have a
perfect square of 4. We use our product rule, to split up this one radical into
the multiplication of three radicals. We know the square root of 4 is 2 and the
square root of 9 equals 3. And finally, we multiply 3 times 2 which equals 6
which is multiplied by the square root of 5, since we can't simplify it. This
was perhaps the longer way to do the problem. Notice that we have two smaller
perfect squares here. Well if we multiply these together we would get 36. So we
really know that 180 is the same thing as 5 times 36. So instead, if we rewrote
180 as 5 times 36, we could have 6 times the square root of 5, since the square
root of 36 equals 6. We can get to this answer more quickly, by splitting up
our original radicand into the largest product of a perfect square and another
factor. By using the largest perfect square here, we get directly to the
answer.